サッバパパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ サチッッタパリオダパナン エタング ブッダナ サーサナン
では よろしくお願いします
あの今日はあの 一応月例講演会はなかなか講演会できなくなってまして
まあその代わりに今日は一つのテーマに絞ってお話をしたいと思います
今日のテーマは この責任を果たすということで
で 何かメールで質問がありましてね
あの仏教はね 出家に教えているもので
そんなのは在家にできるわけないでしょうというふうな感じのね
だから仏教はね 全部責任も捨てて
もう自分だけの幸福のために頑張るでしょうか
あるいは在家に 特別に在家の在家として実践できるものあるのかというふうな意味合い入ってる質問がありまして
まあですから この責任を果たすというテーマで話したいと思います
そこで副題として 自由と責任の対立について仏教的なアプローチ
そこで問題は 仏教は解脱っていうことは
この究極の自由なんですね
一切何にも依存しない
いわゆる究極の自由 究極の自由といえば
この相対的である存在そのものも乗り越えなくちゃいけないということになりますね
だから相対が消えたら人間には概念がないんですね
比較する感覚もないんですね
だから涅槃についてあまり言葉では語れないと
インエフェメルと英語で言いますね
イネフェバイ というのは
涅槃とはという場合は
イネフェバイといわゆる言葉で表現不可能ということになっています
だから責任と自由というと
あまりあの正反対になるんですね
だから面白いですよ じゃあ責任放棄は自由でしょうか？というね
いろんなことを考えられます
では 話を進めていきます
それであの一般的に責任といっても
英語だったらレスポンシビリティーアンドデューティーという 2つありますね
それでレスポンシビリティーっていうのは
自分自身で自分の意思で行うもの
それが まあ一般的に言う自己責任
自分の責任です その場合はデューティーっていうのは
他人に与えられたものでね
他人のためにまたは自分のために行うもの
しかし 仕事は他人が言うんですね
それはデューティー 日本訳すると義務ですね
例えば あの いろいろね
あの ああしなさい こうしなさいと命令する場合は
その命令した人のためか
誰かのためになりますね
例えば このお寺を掃除機をかけてくださいと言われたら
自分自身のためではなくてね
みんなのためにやることになって
それはデューティーになっちゃうんですね
責任ではないんです できませんとも言えますからね
例えば 子供たちにしっかり勉強しなさいと
4時から6時半まで宿題の時間だよと
と母親が あるいは学校の先生が命令すると
それはデューティーになっちゃうんですね
子供はもう嫌ですということもできますけど
まあまあやった方がいいということになりますね
その場合は じゃあ勉強したら誰のため？お母さんのためじゃなくて
本人のためなんです ですから
義務は自分のためか他人のためになる行為で
他人が指令する それはデューティー
この 2つ簡単に重ねてしまうんですね
結局は 例えば勉強することは子供は嫌がっても子供の責任でもありますね
で 教える側が指令しなくちゃいかんですね
だからデューティーにもなります
義務にもなりますね だから義務と責任がダブってしてしまうことになりますね
それで義務は断ることもできるケースがありますね
断れる義務 言われたものは義務ですからね
指令されたら義務ですよ
でも断ることもできる場合もできない場合もありますよ
責任は他人の指令ではないので
果たさなくてはいけないことになっています
責任はそうじゃない 誰かが言ったわけじゃないんです
自分自身から生じる やらなくてはいけないことなんですね
それからは逃げられませんね
そういうことで 責任と義務という 2つのことがあることと
すべて明確に区別して
別々にしゃべらなくてもいいので
総括的にこれから責任という概念にまとめて話を進めていきます
それで責任って面白いんですね
だからいつでもあの裏に義務という言葉が隠れているということを覚えてください
責任というのは増えるもの
生まれてくると自分の命を守るという責任パッケージは持っているんです
生まれてくる赤ちゃんにも責任があるんです
ええと思うかもしれませんよ
パッケージ持って生まれてくるんです
赤ちゃんも自分で生きなくちゃいかんですね
赤ちゃんにあの あの あの
あの なんとかインキュベーターという箱に入れて育てる羽目になっちゃうと困りますよ
重度の未熟で生まれたらね
あの箱に入れて いくらか自立できるまで育てますけど
赤ちゃんが自分でおっぱい吸わなくちゃいけない
自分で呼吸しなくちゃいけない
自分で手足をハチャメチャ動かしちゃって
体を作らなくちゃいけない
いろんなものを握ったり
あれやこれやとやったりしてね
周りのことを勉強しなくちゃいけない
いろんな責任がありますよ
パッケージ持って生まれるんです
だいたい赤ちゃん問題ないんで
まあ子供はだいたいパッケージ通りにやっちゃいますね
ちょっと筋肉がついてくると
もうはいはいしたり 立ってみようとしたり
まあいろんなことをやってますよ
だから立つことでも 赤ちゃんにとっては大変な仕事ですよ
全くバランスがない体だからね
その上 頭がすごく重いんですよ
子供たちの あれは細い首でもう支えられないんですね
だから頭がガクッとどこかに行っちゃうと
立った赤ちゃんがドカンと倒れてしまいますね
そういうことなんですが
まあ赤ちゃんが自分の責任を果たしているんだから
今まで誰も赤ちゃんのことで赤ちゃんの性格が悪いと失笑されたことはないんですね
それから様々な責任が増えていくんですね
わかりやすいことですよ
ずっと赤ちゃんでいるわけじゃないんだからね
大人になると進んで責任を増やす人々もいます
で 大人になっている過程でね
まあ大体子供を例にしちゃうとわかりやすいんだから
まあ子供はまあ学校に行って勉強するだけではなくて
自分でもいろんな課題を考えて
いろんなことをやったりするんですね
昆虫 夏になっちゃうと昆虫を殺したりとかね
まあ蝶々をやっつけたりとかね
まあ自分なりの まあいろんなことを考えたりはする
それで責任増える 増えて増えていくだけでもないんですね
責任はこの減ることもあります
だから 年とともに責任が増えるけど
年とともにあらゆる責任がOK
もうこれで終わり これは終わり
これは終わりっていう風に減っていく責任もありますね
それで最後に 時々愚かな人々はね
世界の責任を自分で担わなくちゃいけないと思っているアホもいますからね
しかし 病気になって死ぬ羽目になっちゃうと
全部放棄して中止して死ななくちゃいけないんですね
その場合は 義務も責任も両方死ぬ瞬間で
そこまでで終わっちゃうんですね
アメリカの大統領であっても
世界に迷惑をかけてもう生きていたっても
突然何かになってもう亡くなる羽目になっちゃうと
すぐ病気で倒れた時点で
責任は誰かに 大統領としての義務
責任 義務ですけど まあそこは別の誰かに行くんです
自分がもうそこで止まるんですね
まあ責任っていうのはそういうものなんですね
で 他人に頼んでやってもらう責任もないんです
義務はできますけどね
まあ例えばご飯食べることやら呼吸することやらね
私はちょっと調子が悪いんだから
代行でやってくださいと
まあ成り立たないんです
だから責任というと かなり自分の存在とすごい一体になっているんですね
そこでたくさん責任がある人
たくさん義務を抱えている人が亡くなると
どうしますかね？困る
困りません この世の中でどんな人間が亡くなっても
世界にはいかくもかいこうもないんです
イギリスのエリザベス女王も私よりも年の方ですけど
まああと100年いるわけじゃないでしょうしね
例えば 失礼ですね 生きている人にそういうのはね
まあ説法のために使いますけど
あの その方が亡くなったからといって英国が滅びるということは全くないんです
あの あの文化がね 王様がいるというね
文化は 1 日にして消えたということでもないんだよ
誰かが次にの王になるでしょうね
それは我々わかりません
誰かと それも覚えておいてください
なぜならば 我々は何か自分がこれやらなかったら世界が滅びると思っているんだからね
そんなことはないんです
例えば お母さんたちが時々
子供を産んですぐ亡くなる場合もありますね
だから子供を産んじゃうと
子供を赤ちゃん育てることはパッケージでお母さんの仕事なんです
その能力は自然法則によってお母さんに付いているんです
だから能力あるからその責任を果たしてくださいっていう
まあ宇宙的な生命法則なんですね
なのに 何かしらなるようで
妊娠お産中亡くなる場合もあるし
あるいはもうお産終わってから何かの病気で命が亡くなることもあります
それでお母ちゃんも一緒に死ぬ
死なない 赤ちゃん知らないもん
お母さんが亡くなったってことを
それはだから他の誰かがその責任をやっちゃいますね
その場合は その人にとっては責任プラス義務になるんですね
はい 次に行きます はい
次のポイントは責任と執着ということ
はい だからこれは仏教の見解から
説明しますので 俗世間のその同じテーマのことは喋りませんね
で しかし 今日は経典からは引用しません
なぜならば そうすると量が膨大になってしまいますので
これは一般的な紹介的な意味なんですね
責任と執着 人は死な...死にたくないんですね
それははっきりしています
これは存在欲というし
これは私が使う単語で
専門用語は渇愛なんですね
タンナーですね どんな生命にも渇愛があるんです
生きていきたいという衝動が生まれたら
パッケージで入ってます
だからこの生前義務というんですかね
生まれて生まれると同時に
これは妊娠した時点でもその責任がありますけど
生きていきたいということは
それはなんで責任ですかというと
自分でそう思っているんだからね
生かってくれって それはありえませんよ
誰かが世間が悪い 親が悪いとかね
学校が悪い だから私はこんなだらしない人間になったのでと言ったならば
それは病気以外何ともないんです
生きることは自分の責任で責任です
勉強することは 立派な大人になることは自分の責任なんです
だからそれはわかってほしいんです
だからそこはなんでそうなるのかというと
一般人にはわからないんですね
例えば 学校でトラブった人が学校が悪いと断言して言ってますよ
それで私が割り込んで違いますよと言っても
その人はあれやこれやとデータ持ってくるんです
いじめられたとかね 先生はみんなの前で自分のプライドを傷つくような言葉を言いましたとかね
だからしたがって学校が悪い
終わり 決定 判決 判決するんですね
だからそこら辺でこの一般人がわからないんだから
世間では間違ったところで解決しようとする
子供たちに勉強しやすい
気持ちよく勉強できる学校システムを作ろうではないかと
まあ表面的には悪くないんだけど
勉強するっていうことは嫌いで嫌々でやるもんだから
気分爽快な環境を作っちゃうと勉強しないんです
そうすると子供たちが学校でゲームセンターを作ってくれと言うでしょうね
そこで渇愛があるということで
存在欲があるんだからこそ
責任というものは成り立つんです
生きることは 地球の自転のように自然に起こるものではないんですね
責任果たすことが生きることです
人は意図的に意思を生かかす
生かして生きているんです
生きていきたいという衝動を使って
渇愛を使って頑張らなくちゃ生きていられないんです
渇愛があるならば 生きることは自分の第一の責任になります
だから すべての生命の責任第一は生きることです
生き延びるために行う様々な行為は
その人のもろもろの責任なのです
ですから はい 生きていきますと言ったってもね
それは成り立たない 何かしやらなくちゃいけない
だから生きることは自分の責任で
生きるためにどうすれば
何すればいいかといって
いろんなことを選んで選んでやってますね
そう それ それで個人 この責任というセットが現れてくるんです
だからそれは個性があります
生きるためにみんな同じワンパターンの責任を果たしているわけじゃないんです
それぞれ個人のプログラムありますね
生きることに執着がないとするならば
その人は責任から解放されます
自由になります もし人がの心から生きていなくちゃあかん
死にたくはないという気持ちが消えちゃったらどうしますか？そこで責任の負担が消えるんです
責任を果たせないではないんですが
負担が消えちゃうんです
生きることというのは
自然な物事の現象の流れですよと
様々な原因で成り立っているものだと
だから別に私というものはないでしょうとかわかったら
すごく気楽にはなるんです
そこであの精神的な悩みはないんですね
だからそこで自由ということになるんです
はい 次に責任を果たす時の問題
変でしょ 生まれてくると渇愛がパッケージに入っている
そうすると生きていなくちゃいけない
責任が自然にある だったら自然で責任を果たすことできるはずでしょうに
問題が起こるんですね
責任を果たすことこそが自分の人生のすべてだと思う人もいる
だから あらゆる勝手な
まあいらん責任もいる
責任も ガチャガチャいろんなことを考えて
これこそ人生やと思って
それに命かける人もいる
2番目 責任を果たす時
失敗して悩んだり苦しんだりする人もいる
責任を果たそうと思ったところでうまくいかなかった
失敗しました それでかなりショックを受けちゃいますよ
結構悩む 悩んだりしますね
3番目は 自分に関係ないことにも手を出して
自分の責任じゃないんだけど
それも私がやります あれも私がやりますとかね
いろんなことに手を出すんです
そこで自分にはあ 生きているんだという気持ちがプラスになります
だからいらんことまで
でやろうとする 例えば旦那様に買い物を頼んだと
奥様がね はい ついでに隣の奥さんの買い物もしてあげますって言って
隣に行って 私は買い物に行くんだけど
あの あの妻のお使いで
何かそちらに必要なものありますかと
なんかおかしくない？で
もし隣の奥様 あ それでよかった
お願いします このリストですよと
私はと本人がえらく頑張ってるんだよというえらい調子に乗ってますよ
関係ない責任まで自分で担ってしまってね
しかしそれで傍迷惑になるんです
結局は それから責任をごまかす人もいる
当然トラブル起こるんです
責任はごまかすことはできないんです
5番目 責任をさぼったり
ごまかすこと サボることは違うんですね
サボるということはやらないことなんで
ごまかすということはやったようにすることなんですね
あれは果たさなかったりして
社会の迷惑になる人もいる
責任をサボる人は社会の迷惑
親に迷惑 家族に迷惑 社会に迷惑
国に迷惑 地球に迷惑 責任を巧みに果たして
さらに自分の人格を向上する人もいる
自分に自然の流れでパッケージで入っている責任をサッサッサッサッとこなして終わってしまって
それから自分自身をこう人格を向上するために
もうちょっとやることないのかと探して
それもやる人々もいる
それから自己責任を果たしながら
他人のためにも努力する人もいますね
それは福祉 ボランティアなどなどに入るところなんですね
だから自分ではまあ責任を果たし
しっかり生きていて 余裕もできて
そこで人のためにも何かやろうではないかと
それも自分が生きているからですよ
自分の存在があるからなんですよ
例えば すごくまあ 自分の人生は全然問題なく
時間の余裕もある方が
ではボランティアに入りますと
それでいろんなボランティア活動
福祉活動をする それで人々はすごく役に立つ
良いことでしょう しかし
これも自分自身の明るく活発に元気で
せっかく生きているんだからね
生きようという努力になりますね
だから渇愛はどうしても隠れてはいるんです
そこで 8番目まれですけど
存在欲を足す人もいる
だから責任を放棄するんじゃないんです
責任 別なことで この責任を作って作って
限りなく責任を作ってくれる
この衝動をストップしてみるんです
そうすると 自然法則によって成り立つ責任だけ残るんです
わざわざあれは作った責任じゃないんです
例えば お腹が空いたらご飯を食べなくちゃいけない
それは自然法則です そこをグルメにしようかなと
かなり腕を振った料理にしようかなと思っちゃうと
存在欲が割り込んでくる
だから存在欲を足したい人は
肉体を維持する自然法則によって成り立つ責任を果たしてますけど
苦しくはないんです ストレスはないんですね
自由です  文字化すると
まあいいや もう生き生き生き生き続ける行為もやめますと
呼吸することもじゃあやめてみますと
いうこともやろうとすればできますけど
わざわざとなんでそれやるのかと
それすらないんです だから
阿羅漢になった人々は
ただそのまま日常のことをやりながらいるんですね
存在欲はないんです ジャイナ教みたいに
では自殺しますということはないんです
ジャイナ教も阿羅漢っていう単語も使っちゃうし
まあ一応いろいろ単語使ってますけど
あのほとんどは宗教二つですから
あのハイライトの言葉は別々に出ていますけど
ジャイナ教はケーバリーという言葉を使うし
仏教は阿羅漢という言葉を使うし
しかし 言葉は行ったり来たりしますよ
仏教でも完成させた人にケーバリーという単語もたまに稀に使う
でもジャイナ教の PR フレーズだからあまり使わない
阿羅漢果に達したということは
ジャイナ教でもたまたま使うんだけど
あれは仏教の人々の PR フレーズだからということで
あまり使わないということになっていて
まあだから一緒に生活した宗教二つですからね
はい それで仏教が言うのはね
なんでジャイナ教の人々は修行の最終的には自殺するのかと
で 世間にある自殺と違いますよ
あれはかなり高度な自殺なんです
要するに 自分で自分の修行をできるぐらい体力
能力がある限り 自分の苦行ですけど
苦行をする 自分で人のためにやるべきことはできる範囲でギリギリまでやる
できるだけ欲のない欲少ない生活をする
そこであるステージに来たら何もできなくなるんです
自分が生きることが周りに迷惑になっちゃう
周りに負担になる 他人の責任になる
自分が生きることは自分の責任でしょ
そこで体が弱くなって
年取って 自分で何もできなくなったところで
自分が生きることは周りの責任になってくるんです
その時点で ジャイナ修行者は断食するんです
で 亡くなるんです だからあの
その その宗教では そういう自殺を素晴らしい善行為として認めてはいるんですね
仏教の立場から見ても
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみで亡くなったわけじゃないし
敗者で負け犬で亡くなったわけでもないし
堂々とではさようなら
これ以上私を生かす必要はないんだと
ただ断食するだけ あの毒飲んだりはしませんよ
ビルから飛び込んで降りたりはしません
なぜなら そういう他人に迷惑なんです
ただ絶食それだけ 誰に迷惑じゃありません
でも仏教はそれはにはなんとなく悪口言うんですね
だから私がこれからじゃあ亡くなることにしますというふうにね
まあ余計なことやと ということにしているんですね
はい ではさらに仏教の話
それからあれは俗世間のセクションの終わりもあったけど
あまり詳しく説明しません
できるだけ時間を短く使いたいんです
責任に対して仏教の立場
責任とは 呼吸するような感じで自然に果たすものですよ
だから誰かが呼吸することに困ったことがある
呼吸することに困ったことがあったら
それは大きな問題で 病気で病院に行かなくちゃいけないんですね
だからこの毎日呼吸するような感じで
喉が渇いたら水を飲むような感じで
自分の責任をすごく自然に軽く果たすもんですよ
大げさに考える必要はないんです
それで俗世間が失敗するんです
ああ 子育てしなくちゃ
ああ 子供の教育についてあれこれやらなくちゃとかね
これで子育ても失敗するでしょ
結婚する女性たちが ああ
もう家事をやらなくちゃとかね
えらい重い負担として責任というか
なんか軍事政権で軍人が指令したような感じで
ハチャメチャストレスを抱えて
誰にでもできることをやっているんです
完璧なバカでしょ 掃除
洗濯ぐらい 料理ぐらいは誰にでも男にできるでしょうに
だからそこら辺は俗世間の愚かなところなんですね
だから仏教から言うのは
こんなのはもう自然の流れだから
呼吸するような感じでやりなさいと
それで話が終わるんです
ですから 私は家族を養っているのだなどと言う必要すらないんです
あ 大変だ 私はもう小学校の子供2人抱えているんだとかね
あれは自分のたくさんの責任を放棄するための言い訳なんです
時々の男同士で激しい戦いに
殴り合いに喧嘩になると
それはたまに男たちがその言葉を使うんです
その場合 私は OK やと思いますよ
例えば すごいもう世間で生きている場合は
もうすごい問題が起きて
もう男同士でハチャメチャ喧嘩することになっちゃって
それで棒を持ったり いろんな武器を持ったり
攻撃し合っちゃうと 一人の男がやめましょうと
私には家族があるんだと
家族を養わなくちゃいけないと言っちゃうと
それで男同士だから じゃあいいや
喧嘩やめましょうということで喧嘩やめるんです
で なぜかというと これ
男同士で喧嘩して怪我して大怪我してね
仕事をできなくなったりしちゃうと
あるいは仕事をクビになったりしちゃうと
自分の責任を果たせなくなっちゃうんですね
家族に対する だからちょっとこの場合はまあ逃してくれと
言って 男のあの喧嘩するプライドを自分で抑えておくんです
ちょっと負けてみるんです
その場合だけですよ このちょっとそういう言葉を使っても構わないのは
それをあえて奥さんに言ってみたらどうですかね
だんだん男たちが 1週間以内で離婚になるんです
大変な危険な言葉なんです
私はお前食べさせているのではないのかと言った時点で自然法則を壊しているんです
で だからお母さんもこんなことを旦那に言っちゃいかんしね
旦那がふざけてるならば叱るのはいいんだけどね
なんとなくすべて自然に流れるような
子供たちも自然で 自分で喜んで勉強するわ
自分も自然の流れで仕事をするわとかいう風にした方がいいと思いますね
他人の頼み義務は次のフレーズ
自分の本来の責任を超えるときは
理性的に断るんです だから人個人個人には責任セットがあるんです
だいたいそれで精一杯です
しかし 社会でいろんなこと言われるんですよ
こうしましょう ああしましょうとかね
コンサートに行きませんか？とかね
みんなで映画館に行って映画を見て
それからどこかのレストランでディナーでもやりましょうかとかね
そういう風に 他人から今日来たメールを見たら
同窓会に参加しませんか
しませんか？とかね いろいろあるんですね
それで そんなことをやると
自分の本来の責任には邪魔だったら
これそれには何かの妨げになるならば
それは断らなくちゃいけない
理性的に いきなり頑固でダメではなくてね
例えば 自分の収入で やっと奥さんがあらゆる工夫をして
やっと家族を養っているんですね
奥様が大変なんです みんなも問題なく
もうちゃんと美味しいご飯を食べて生活するようにしてあげることは
そこで男同士でね どこかに行ってコンサートを見て
それから飲み屋さんでハチャメチャに酒を飲んで
ディナーパーティーもやって
そこに 10万ぐらい使って
行っちゃうと家族のためにあげるお金がなくなっちゃうんです
そういう場合は断る必要ありますね
それで理性的に断るということは
ちゃんと理由を言って断る
相手にも ああ そうかと納得していただければ一番最高ですね
まあ例も書きましたけどね
学校をサボって遊びに行きましょうと言ったら
やっぱり理性のある子供が断りますよ
在家の人々は出家を考えるときも同じことです
在家で仏教を学んで 突然何か発作を起こしちゃって
じゃあ出家しなくちゃとかね
ちょっと考えてほしいんですね
すぐ実行する前に だから生まれている人間だから
もうパッケージで責任パッケージがあるんです
それは放棄できないんですね
だから考え直さなくちゃいけないんですね
自分の出家は責任放棄でもなく
周りに迷惑でもない人格者になれるなら OK です
周りはまあ別にいいよ
あんたはまあそれでより良い道を目指して頑張るのは構わないよと言ったら
OK なんですね だから仏教では出家する場合は両親の許可を取りなさい
特に若い若者に対してはね
結婚しているならば 奥さんがあなた出家しなさいと言わないと出家できないんです
ということは この責任は放棄ではないんです
そこはなんとか自分がまとめているはずなんですね
はい 次のフレーズに行きます
例えば 自分を養う 家族を養う
他を助けるなどの目的があっても
悪行為してはならない
それで責任を果たすためにも
お釈迦様は悪行為だけはやめてくださいと
この悪行為っていうのは
他人の生きる権利を奪うことなんです
奪うこととか迷惑になる
邪魔になる行為なんですね
あるいは自分自身で怒り
嫉妬 憎しみの感情を作る行為
そうすると責任は果たせないんですね
だから責任という単語を使って善悪を判断する場合は
そういうふうな判断になります
自分が仕事をしなくちゃいけない
自分が自分の家族を養わなくちゃいけない
自分自身の体を維持管理しなくちゃいけない
これ そういう一つからも逃げられません
パッケージです だからといって
他人に迷惑をかけながら
他人の権利を奪うながら
他人の命を絶つながらやると
それは責任を果たしたことじゃないんです
そういうことは決してやるなよと
正しく責任を果たして
物事に執着してはならない
それから俗世間である大きい問題は
執着しちゃうんですね
これ 担いあるんだからね
だから基本的に大変なんですよ
担いがあるんだから執着しちゃうんです
だから仏教の人々に執着
担いが執着まで悪化するところは気をつけて控えてくださいと
これ たとえ話で書いたのは
子育て 子育ては責任ですね
しかし 子供に執着する必要はないんです
子供は自分の所有物だと
自分の財産だと 思う思うことはできないんです
子供は命ですから 誰の財産でもないんです
命あるものは誰の財産にもなりません
ペットを飼ったからって
ペットは命 自分のものじゃないんです
ペットの命はペットの命なんです
そちらそちらの法則で生きているんです
ペットでヘビを飼ったらね
自分はご飯食べるんだから
あるいはペットショップで買ったキャットフードをヘビに食べさせるとか
これは成り立たないんです
飼ったヘビは餌に何するのかって？その餌あげなくちゃいけないんです
はい それでこの えーと
責任は果たす しかし 執着しない
そこで責任があるとは自由がないという意味でしょう
で 子供がある場合は いる場合は
お母さんにお父さんに自由がないんです
はい 子供を育てなくちゃいけないんです
それは責任ですよ その場合
責任でも義務とは言えないんですね
まあ社会は言っちゃっても
やっぱり子供はまあ両親です
養うということは 動物の世界でもあることで
だから義務ではないんですけど
責任ですね だから小さな子供がいるということは
自分が自由でないということなんです
それで責任を果たす 責任果たすと
なんとなく微妙に自由を感じるんです
なんかわずかな自由を感じるんです
で 子供たちが作った料理をちゃんと正しく食べたならば
それで宿題もちゃんとしっかりと時間でやって終わったならば
ゲームやらないで ちゃんと風呂の時間で
じゃあお風呂に入ります
ちゃんとお風呂に入ったならば
お母さんがそこでホッとするでしょ
あれがすごく大事なことなんです
あのわずかな自由が 自分が責任を果たしましたと
うまくいったと だからそれを目指すと
責任なんか見事に果たすということは何のことないんです
自分にそれによって得るものがあるんです
精神的な なんとなく何か満足感というか
何か自由というかね それを感じるんです
例で言えば 子供は独立する
そこで日本だったら両親が追っかけていく
それでも電話かけるは
毎日もうガチャガチャ
あれやったのか これやったのかと聞くわ
考えてください 結婚しているいるんだと
それでお母さんが男に電話して
あんた何々これこれ食べたのかい？とかね
だけど奥さんの機嫌が悪くなるでしょう
ちゃんと野菜食べたのですか？とかね
で ということは 独立した子供に対して執着があるんです
もう責任終わってるんです
あの執着で姑とのトラブルが起こるんです
それでお嫁さんが姑さんに当たっちゃうと
旦那から見れば自分のお母さんだからね
すごく嫌な気分になっちゃうんです
それで家庭崩壊になるんです
家庭崩壊になったのは執着なんですよ
私のものだと思ったところで問題なんです
息子が私のものじゃないんです
赤ちゃんも私のものじゃないんです
ただ 赤ちゃんを抱えているお母さんには
責任が逃げられない責任があるだけで
自由がなくなっただけで
そこで責任を果たし果たして
自分が自由を目指していくんです
そこで独立したら もう手をはい
終わります 一仕事見事に終わりましたと
楽しめばいいんです 楽しむっていうのは
この心の充実感を 自由を感じてみるんです
例えば もうあのずっと料理作っていた人がね
だからみんな独立して出て行っちゃうと
今まで元気で あの いろんなレパートリー
あれは考えてね 献立考えて
気持ちがもう消えちゃうでしょ
そうするとすごい落ち込んじゃうんですね
まあ何か適当に食べれば
なんか人生暗いんだと
前は食卓はすごく賑やかでしたと
いろんな数がいっぱいあったと
で 悩むんですね あれは現実的じゃないんです
その人には執着があるんです
ですから その人は賑やかな食卓をふざけて遊んでいただけで
責任を果たせていなかったんです
だから子供はみんな出て行っちゃって
自分一人か二人だけになったら
あ 楽ちんやと 自分二人の健康に合わせて軽く食事を作って
残り時間で勉強したり
本を読んだり 夫婦で散歩に行ったりして
人生楽しめばいいでしょうに
だから執着があるとそれがなくなるんですね
それで毎日責任を果たすたびに
あのわずかな自由を経験しましょうということは
仏教から提案するアイデアです
大胆な自由ではなく あんなわずかな自由を味わって微笑んでみてくださいと
ああ じゃあ次に行きます
たくさんなりますよね
そこで忙しい人いるんですね
果たせないほどいっぱい責任
義務を作って また奪って
人生を忙しくする人がいるんです
はぁ 忙しいと その人々はちょっと問題なんですよ
例えば あまりにも忙しくて家族の面倒を見ることはできなくなったと
子供の成長の過程で 父親としての義務を果たすことできなかったと
学校に行かなくちゃいけない日とか
なんとかいろいろありますね
それは自分が忙しいと言って参加しなかったとかね
そういう人々は問題なんですね
それで子供がどんどん大きくなって独立しちゃうと
お父さん見て あんた誰？という気分になるんです
それで時々いるんですね
この だからやらなくてもいいのに
わざわざあれも考えて
これも考えて あれもやる
これもやるとか とにかく忙しくいたいんですね
この忙しくいたくなるのは
ちょっと精神的な不安があるからなんですね
やることがなくなってくると
なんか不安 怯え 落ち込みを感じるんですね
だからそういうプログラムに嵌めたら
ハマったらすごくかわいそうですね
何かしら自分自身で何か宿題を考えてやると
これ必要かどうか どうでもいいんですね
それはちょっと困ったもんで
異常欲無知などの問題がありますね
だから存在欲が異常欲になっているんですね
管理できなくなっているんですね
だからじっとしていられなくて
いろんなことをやりだしちゃうんですね
だから いらんことまで責任だと義務だと思ってやると
周りが 逃げたりするでしょう
それでかなり凶暴で その人々に怒鳴ったり
鬼の性格になったりもしますね
だから嫌な存在になるんですよ
それから怠けの人はじきに責任を果たさないので
忙しい気持ちになります
怠け性格の人もいるんですね
あの責任っていうのを果たす時期があるんですね
これ 時間経過したらもう大失敗です
その時間でやらなくちゃいけない
だってね 畑なんか作る方々は知ってるでしょうね
水をあげる時期 栄養をあげる時期
まあいろいろ虫とか取るべき時期とかね
花の面倒もいろんな時期がありますね
それは後回しにできないでしょう
人間としても義務は義務ではなくて
責任は 何時何分かとハッキリ決まってます
だから何時何分程度 そこでもないんだけど
もう大体一日三食と決まったわけじゃなくて
まあせいぜい一食だけでも取らなくちゃいけないんですね
しかし 二日分は一食に取っても意味がないんです
じゃあ明日の食事まで今日食べて終わりますよと
それでは責任を果たしたことにはならないんですね
だからこの怠けが この時期逃しちゃうんですね
機会とも言うんで このチャンスでやらないんです
その中で追っかけてくる責任もある
あるいはもうあんた責任果たさなかった
バッテンとなっておてつく責任もいろいろあります
例えば 一人で生活する男の人が
朝ごはんを食べて 食器はそのまま置いておいて仕事に行く
夜帰ってきて また他の食器を持っていろんな料理を作って食べて
また洗面器 何で洗面じゃなくて洗いあれいに入れて帰ると
責任放棄ですね それで忙しいと
そんな食器洗う暇がないと
嘘でしょ それで悪い結果になってくるんですね
大体はこの怠け性格悪い人々は
この家のことだけではなくて
仕事に行っても何やっても大体中途半端ですね
この完成まで仕事をしないんですね
はい これで終わりましたと
朝ごはん自分で作ったならば
ご飯を食べて 皿も全部洗って
台所も拭いて そこで完成なんです
そうすると なんとなく微かな味を感じるんです
料理を作ると ガスコンロ周りがちょっと汚れたら
じゃあまあまた夜も料理を作るんだからね
それから洗いますと これはもう気持ち悪いはずなんです
では 朝ご飯を作ったらちょっと汚れた
それで綺麗に そこを綺麗にして
なんか料理作ってないコンロのようにしておいて仕事に行くと気分がいいはずなんです
だから この時期に責任を果たすんですよ
怠け者にはそれできないんですね
それから妄想する人にもできなくなっちゃうんですね
責任を果たさないで遊びにふける人
この世でもあの世でも不幸に陥ります
それだけじゃない これはかなり生き方間違ったということになります
例えば遊びに行く いらん友達を作る
自分に関係ない 能力に関係ないことをやろうとすると
それは苦行になりまして
失敗しますね この世でも失敗するし
この世で失敗したらあの世でも失敗します
心配する必要ないんです
不幸に陥ります そういう人々は責任を果たさないで
まあ嫌だ この俗世間はと
俺は出家すると 出家も失敗します
それだけは保証できます
責任放棄する人はすべて失います
はい 次に行きます うん
まだ半分も進んでないんです
で 泳げない魚というタイトルです
いるわけないでしょ 実際いるんですね
泳げなくて溺れて 魚なのに溺れて死ぬ
魚は溺れるということもなんか変でしょ
責任を果たす方を教えることは
世間の仕事で仏教の問題ではありません
だから今日のテーマを聞いた方々は
じゃあ見事に責任を果たす裏技をスマナサーラが教えてくれるだろうと
まああることはありますよ
いくらでも 本10冊ぐらいでも言えます
これはこうします これはこうしましょうと
こんなのは仏教の仕事じゃないんです
俗世間の仕事です 俗世間は渇愛を正当化する世界なんです
仏教は渇愛は苦しみの元であるという世界なんです
だから敵対同士です 敵対っていうのは冗談で使ったんだけどね
ライバル同士です だから正しいおっぱいのあげ方は？仏教を教える意思はある
赤ちゃんの正しい抱き方
教えないったら教えられる
私にはもう結婚したことも何ともないんだけどね
私は赤ちゃんを見事に抱っこしてみせますよ
たまにここでも何回何回もあったんだけどね
我々の仲間の方々 子供が生まれたらちょっと起き上がって祝福してほしいと
ただ 私は起き上げてから赤ちゃんを私の膝の上にドカンと置くんです
お母さんのところでギャーギャーと泣いていた赤ちゃんは
私の膝の上にドカンと置いちゃって
泣かないんです やり方あるんですよ
それだけ だから それは仏教の仕事じゃないんです
人生の伴侶の選び方 なんだこれ
それは自分でやりなさいよと
結婚相手を自分で探せよと
もしかするとなんかこれこれ
まあ私もあります 若い頃ね
あのいろいろたくさん男たちと我々はまあ女の人とあまり友達になっていかんだからね
男たちいっぱいいるんですね
仲間で もう悪ふざけのグループでね
その中でいろいろまあ気に入ってる女がいる男もいるし
で いろいろトラブル だから気に入ってる女の人がいるんだけど
話しかける自信がなくて
で 私に言うんですね 何さんがね
気に入ってるんだけど
なんか話せないんだよとかね
で 私が言って その女の子にこっちおいで
君のこと この男は好きになってるんだから仲良くしなさい
言えませんよ その子にどうやって気が引く
どうすれば気が引くのかといういろいろな技を教えてあげるんです
だからそれは説法で言う
それが説法 スリランカではそんな話ばっかり説法でするお坊さんたちもいますけど
大人気なんですね 結構金を儲かっているんです
だから仏教の仕事は この人生は生きることを客観的に分析して
問題点を客観的に発見
それは普遍的な真理なんですね
問題点を発見して 解決策を見つけて
この解決を実践する方法を提案することです
だから かなり大きなスケールで物事を見ているんです
料理の塩加減どうしますか？って話じゃないんです
そこを理解してください
だから私はそれを理解するためにあの例を使ったんです
泳げない魚 人間ですよ
泳げない魚は だから人間って当然知るべきことは知らない
知らないんだったら 親から先輩から友達から学べばいいでしょうに
料理の腕を あまり料理が上手でないならば
誰か誰か友達から教えてもらえばいい話でしょうに
それにお寺に来る必要はないでしょうに
だからこのインチキ宗教ありますよ
例えば 旦那さんがあまり家のことには無関心とかね
できるだけ遅くになってから家に戻る
もう計画を意図的にやっているんだと
家にいたくなくなっちゃうんだと
そうするとインチキ宗教に行って
ああ それはそれはこのご先祖様の怨念があってね
で なんとかこのお守り持っていってください
それはすべて嘘なんですけど
だから仏教の話ではないんです
仏教はその場合はお守りを作ってあげませんだけど
やり方は教えてあげるんです
でも本則じゃないんです
仏教の えーと 責任果たすことで失敗するならば
泳げない魚のようです
泳げない魚になっている人間に
理性とともに理性と物事を客観的に見ることを教えます
そこで この泳げない魚になっている人間に
仏教は理性を教えるんです
こうこう風にしてくださいと
いろんな宿題を出して
レッスンを出して 理性が上がるようにするんです
私の辛口もだいたいこの理性に訴えているんです
例えば 私は信仰 宗教 組織とは何の恨みもないんです
それに一つ悪口いうことで
理性に私は訴えているんです
人の物事を客観的に見ること
理性があれば大体問題は解決します
責任の問題は それもダメなら時々バカがいるんですね
理性もないし どうすればいいかわからないし
その人々は仏教の仲間だったら
仏教は仏教にもそれで責任が生じてくるんです
仏教徒であるならば その場合はお前盗むなかれと
邪な行為するなかれと
怠けないで汗ながら仕事をしろよと
金入るからといって何でもやるなよと
合法っていうのは俗世間の法律ではなくて
仏教の真理ですね 真理を犯してでも金儲けるなよ
地獄に落ちますからと
そういうふうに派手な具体的な説法をする場合もあります
親が残した財産で食うなよと
自分でも財産作れよと
収入があったら一部貯金しなさいよと
仏教の仕事じゃないでしょ
それは明確に分かります
お釈迦様が 4 分の 1 貯金しなさいとおっしゃったんです
収入の あの言葉 現代に合わないんです
それはシガラコジに合うんです
シガラコジが商人なんです
だから投資して収入を得ているんです
だから結構金があるんです
だから  4 分の 1 は貯金することができます
だから収入の 4 分の 2
半分をさらに投資する
それでお釈迦様は簡単におっしゃっただけで
細かい説明に行かないんですね
そこで収入といったら
このロスインカムなんです
現代の言葉で言えば ロスインカム
何でしたっけ？ 収入全体ってことですか
収入全体 いわゆる全部
俺 これからそれ その収入から給料を払わなくちゃいけないし
あれこれいろんなそこやったら
あのプロフィットが純利益が出てくるんですね
だから総合的な売り上げと実際の利益って 2つなの
お釈迦様はってお釈迦様に関係ないんです
だから半分投資しなさいと
だからシガレさんがそこを理解して
実際自分の責任だからどう使うのかと
ブッダの教えを使ったでしょうに
これ 現代人もあの経典を文字通りに読んでやっちゃうと
もうどうなるんですかね
今みんな給料ですからね
そこの半分投資できるわけないでしょうに
しかし 貯金はいくらかできる
はい そういうことで このあまりこの責任を果たすことは
まあそれなりの経典がありますよ
いくつかの経典がありますけど
今日は意図的に取り上げてないんです
これは管轄外やと はい
次に行きます 律 がある人の人生プログラム
そこでその代わりに人生プログラムあるんですね
理性があるならば 俗世間的な責任は何のこともなく果たしているんです
理性があるならば こんな呼吸やっているような感じで
全部はいはいはい わかりましたという感じで
パッパッパッと全部やっちゃいます
その人に世間制覇して生きていても
死後持っていけるものは何もないのだと
結局空しいのだと説くんです
そこで私 仏教はそこからあなたは物の見事に財布の人を通して何一つ文句のない生き方していますよと
だから私はわざわざこの極端な単語を使ったんです
世界制覇していると まあありえない話ですけどね
まあ例えばある国の大統領になった
総理大臣になったと もう国を支配しているでしょうに
まとめてそこまで責任ちゃんと果たしているんです
それで仏教はね あんた物の見事に責任を果たしているんだけどね
虚しいよ あんた死ぬ時は総理大臣というあれ
ライセンス持っていけませんだからね
子供 3人も世界国際レベルの科学者に育て上げましたと
でも死ぬ時は連れて行けませんよ
生きることは総合的に評価すると空しいんだよと覚えておけと
だから生きること空しいと明るくわかるのはしっかり責任果たす人なんです
怠け者んじゃないんです
怠け者が生きること空しいっていうのは怒りなんです
病気なんです 成功する人の言葉なんだ
あれは その人は生きることから逃げるのではなく
プラスアルファで人生について観察するんです
だから責任は淡々と果たせるし
それはそれで 人生っていうのはそういうものですね
奴隷のように働くだけだから
もうちょっと考えることはないのかとかね
だから奴隷にならない精神をつくろうではないかと
心清らかにしようではない
そこをやるんですね 渇愛
生きる苦しみ 執着の問題
体も心 心も自由ではないことを観察するんです
渇愛について勉強してみる
生きる苦しみについて勉強してみる
執着の問題 勉強してみる
責任果たす人にもそれはよくわかりますよ
社会で生きているんだから
それから体も自由がない
えっ？心にも自由がないと
みんな思考の自由あると思ってるでしょ
仏教の人は知ってます
心の自由すらないんだと
心が勝手に妄想回転しているんだと
やめなさいと言ったらやめてくれないんだよと
そこで私って一体何なのかといったら
いないんだとわかるでしょ
それが預流果の悟りでしょう
責任を果たす果たすロボットではなく
自分で判断する 考察する人間になります
はい そういうふうに仏教は
この理性の まず理性を提案して
推薦して それからプログラムを作ってあげているんです
お釈迦様は責任の正しい果たし方ではなくて
人生設計を教えているんです
どれほど完璧 見事な教えかと
はい より良い生き方 悩み
妄想 無駄話などを控えて責任を上手に果たす
だからそれは仏教のとの生き方です
悩み 妄想 無駄話 控える
控える できるだけ こんなのは役に立たん
こんなのは役に立たんやと
悩んだっても意味がないやと
例えば自然災害に遭遇しても悩んで泣いたりしません
仏教とは すぐにどうすればと
思うんだ ずっと私の頭にこびりついている画像があってね
かなり昔 テレビでね バンコクは洪水で全部ストップになっちゃったんです
だから政府はと軍隊が王様の宮殿だけ水が入らないようにカットしたんで
全部流れる水が街に行っちゃって
街がみんな屋根の上 もう 1 メートルぐらい水
王様だけ守ればいいと思っているんだ
一般人はどうでもいいや
まあそれでもボランティアの人々やいろんな人々は
この人々はこの避難所にボートで運ぶんですよ
そこで屋根の上に子供たちは４人ぐらい座っていたんですね
そこでボートが来て ボートに乗せて避難所に持っていくと
どこかでカメラ どうせ NHK のあれで見たんだからね
カメラと子供たちはニコニコ撮られてカメラに手を振っているんです
あれがすごく私にね 脳にこれ映像が残ったんです
自分の家がもう屋根まで浸水しているのに
このガキたちの明るさはそのまま
だったら あれに悩むよりはボートの旅を喜んじゃってね
カメラも抱えているならば
ちょっと手を振ってニコって笑ってあげちゃえばもう楽しいでしょうね
もう やっぱりタイ人の遺伝子にも仏教的な生き方が刻んでいるなと
その瞬間でわかったんです
はい 他人のために福祉活動もする
仏教との責任ですよ 一つ責任というよりは
自分の責任を見事に果たして時間が余るんですね
プラスアルファで福祉活動はいろんなことをする
仏教ではもう嫌になるほどいろんな福祉活動を教えていますからね
心配なく いくらでもあります
関係ある人々だけではなく
たくさんの人々の役に立つように生き方をする
私と私の子供たちだけで幸せということは
仏教の世界ではないんです
関係ない人でも はい どうぞというふうな世界なんです
心を清らかにすること
落ち着いていることを学ぶ
だから私も聞いたことあるんだけどね
母親がちっちゃい時 ご飯作ったら
まあもうむさぼって食べちゃうんです
怒鳴るんですね お母さん
ああ みんな喜んで食べてくれてよかったね
それがないんだよ 自分のお母さんが
なんだ この食べ方は こんなむさぼって食べて豚に生まれ変わりたいのかと
ですから 丁寧に行儀よく
何て言いますか 品格よく食べなさいよと言うんです
ですから まあそれも仏教のアドバイスなんですね
はい 心を清らかにすること
落ち着いていることはすぐね
で 智慧を育てて 無執着の生き方について学んで理解する
無執着の生き方はいきなりできないかもしれませんだけど
無執着の生き方はこういうものであるとちゃんと学んで
ちゃんとプログラムを頭に入れておくんですね
生き方そのものを善行為にする
だから普通 朝起きてご飯作って
あれやこれやとマンダリンのシステムを善行為にするんです
だから自分の国のことしか知らんんだけど
やっぱりあの 我々はいつでも慈悲の言葉は日常茶飯事で挨拶代わりに使う
植物にすごく優しく話しかけながら
植物の面倒を見る 植えた花にはどうせ暑い国だからね
毛虫がいるんですよ 我々には年中ね
まあ虫がいるし 蝶々たちもいろんな種類によって時期違いますけど
いるし だから追っかけて殺す必要はないしね
いつだっていたらいるんだからね
自分がせっかく育てた花の上に毛虫がはいって食ってやるぞと言ったら怒るんじゃないんですね
殺虫剤はかけませんよ
どうしても花が食べてほしくないんだったら
あの毛虫を丁寧にとって別なところに置いておくんです
ここら辺食べてよと だからそちらに毛虫はこんなの食いませんよと花食いたいと言ってるかどうかはわかりませんだけど
そこで優しい気持ちだけはあるんですね
だから生き方は全体的に善行為にするんです
心の煩悩を落とす努力をする
毎日でもやっぱり煩悩は良くないとかね
だから仕事をする時 商売をやっている時
いろんなことをやっている時は
なんとなく気持ちが出てくると
あ これは煩悩 これは欲
これは怒りとかね そこは控えておくんです
商売はしますけどね はい
はい 次 もうガクンとテーマ変わります
出家習慣と責任 仏教の話ですからね
あの仏教 ブッダの社会は出家というんだからね
それと責任の関係は何なのかと
仏道の出家は 俗世間との関係を切って家なき生活することですね
それはそんなに難しい課題ではないんです
家に上がると言うんですね
とは俗世間という意味なんです
あの物質的な家 建物ではないんです
ワールドリーライフというね
世間の生き方 意味で 家族を持つことも
経済 政治活動も その他のことも
世間に関わることをすべてやめるんですね
やめての生き方は出家の生き方なんです
責任を果たせないで夜逃げ
だから日本の単語は夜逃げですけど
夜逃げることですけど
仏教の言葉は世に世の世から逃げることです
出家社会に入って気楽に生きようと思う人もいるんですね
いるんです なんか責任を果たせない
果たしたくない それでみんなギャーギャーギャーギャーいろんなこと言うんだから
自分自身でも気持ち悪いんですね
怠け者で 引きこもりで
仕事もしないで 大人の親のご飯食って
で 親が亡くなったら俺の収入もなくなっちゃうよと
いいこと出家しようと思っちゃうんです
出家っていうのは この夜逃げ修禅じゃないんですけどね
そういう人もいるんです
世間 社会の責任を果たす果たしたくないとは問題です
その人には生まれると
この精神パッケージをちゃんとやってないんだから
根本的な問題あるんです
やってるのはご飯食うことと呼吸する程度でしょうに
それだけじゃパッケージじゃないでしょうに
勉強しなくちゃいけない
仕事をしなくちゃいけない
友達関係を作らなきゃ
人間と仲良くしなくちゃいけない
いろんな責任があるでしょうに
やってないんです 責任というのはいろいろトラブルも起こりますよ
仕事に行っても仕事はきついとか
上司の性格が厳しいとかね
だから仕事を辞める じゃあ報告を出す
上司が優しいところに就職したいと報告出してみて
誰かはい 私はあなたを雇うますという人が出てくるかと
何考えているのかよくわからない
この世間の人間は理性は全くないんですね
何か精神的な病にかかっているんです
だからそういうのは 俗世間ではね
心理学者の先生たちは精神病やと言わんだけど
僕は精神病と言うんですね
はい 続きます 出家は責任放棄社会であるならば問題がありませんよ
出家とは責任放棄の手段ですと
出家は精神病人 世間の敗者たちのたまり場になりますね
そうするとお釈迦様第 一号で
世界一だらしない人 だったら二五〇〇年もこの仏教は続くわけないでしょう
怠け者のたまり場で 出家は戦争があっても
で 十六年間スリランカで昔乾季があったんです
だからファミリー食べるものがなくて
人々は木の皮まで食べることになっちゃったんです
お布施はないでしょう
それでお坊さんたちがお経を覚えて
次の世代に与えたんです
当時で経典 本に書いてなかったんです
全部暗記で暗記するシステムがあったんです
そこであまりにも乾季状態が続くんだから
お坊さんたちがまとめて
別れたんです 一部があの学者と若者たちがたくさんインドに行ったんです
まだ南インドの方ですけどね
一部は 私たちはね いくらなんでも来る人は苦しんでいる時は逃げるわけにいかんとスリ
止まったんです そこで乾季が終わってインドに行ったお坊さんたちはまた帰ってきたんですね
帰ってきたら お坊さんたち同士でちょっとした血筋を会議やってみたんです
で インドのお坊さんというのは
全部経典を暗記して暗記してリピートして弟子たちに覚えて
それを伝えているんです
そこでそちらのどうやって覚えて
どこいくとチェックするんです
それでスリランカでご飯もなく
食べるものなく もう痩せて骨だらけでいたお坊さんたちも
自分が覚えたものはまた繰り返して暗唱して見せるんです
そうすると一言葉にも差がなかったと
あの膨大な三蔵経典で
怠け者にできる そんなのは
責任放棄する者にできる
スリランカという国には歴史もない
文化もないんです お坊さんたちのあのすごい力強い態度がなければ
ただの文明もなく野蛮人になるんです
だから遠い昔からもう紀元前
もうかなり前からもうあれは国際国でしたから
中国から来るは インドから来るは
ギリシアから来るは まあ行ったり来たり
そうすると あのちっちゃな島っていうのは
なんか立場がなくなるでしょうに
でも 自分の独特文化 仏教文化
しっかりアイデンティティを守っていたんです
閉鎖していないんです
だから現実的には出家比丘サンガっていうのは
負け敗者たちのたまり場じゃないんです
責任放棄する精神病人のたまり場じゃないんです
出家は責任放棄ではありません
だから責任放棄ではありません
一般人に果たすことも想像することをそれは抜けています
難しい高度な責任を果たす努力する世界です
一般人にはちょっとかなわないので
わかりやすい例を書いたんですね
オリンピックを目指す目指す若者が
同年代の仲間といることを一切やめているんです
本当に明るくて元気でいい若者と子供たちですよ
遊びに行かないんです
文句も言いません オリンピックに出たいんです
メダル取りたいんです
だから同年代のその他の人々にできない修行をやってますよ
すごい厳しい訓練をしています
出家はそういうふうに考えてもらわないと
ですから 出家は能力者の
組合でしたっけ 組合組合であって
敗者たちの集いではありません
歴史的にもいませんよ
たまにいるんですよ もう負けて還俗するとかね
だから還俗という言葉すら
仏教ではすごくなんか汚点のように感じるんです
経典では還俗したケース一つ二つぐらいあるし
そこでミャンマー人 タイ人
みんな還俗しているでしょ
男性は あれはちょっと違う文化なんですね
一人前になれませんよと
最低 1ヶ月間でも出家しないと結婚できませんと
だからタイ人なんかは恋人ができて
結婚しなくちゃいけないことになっちゃうと
結婚準備する前にお寺に相手出家するんです
そこで最低だいたい１年ぐらいはいるんです
あるいは最低３ヶ月間ぐらいでも真面目に修行するんです
ふざけているわけじゃないんです
それで堂々と還俗して結婚するんです
だから タイ ミャンマーの文化見ても
出家っていうのは こういう責任放棄者の世界じゃないってことわかるでしょ？なんでタイ人
ミャンマー人 みんな男はね
一時出家するんですかね
より良い責任持てる人間になるためなんです
腰抜けにならないためになんです
泣き入りしない人間になるためなんです
はい 具体的精神的障害がある場合は
出家修行は耐えられないので哀れみを持って禁じているのです
だから出家する人々もちょっとした選別試験ではないんだけど
するんです 資格があるかないかと
何かの障害を持っていると
あなたにはちょっと厳しいすぎだからやめた方がいいと
体の障害がある場合でも
障害者を差別しているわけじゃなくて
体に障害を持っていると
あの出家としての修行は難しいんですね
精神障害があると当然話にもならない
瞑想しなくちゃあかんだから
仏教を学ばなくちゃあかんだから
説法せなくちゃあかんだからね
話にもなる はい 次行きます
責任が多い出家なんです
だから出家っていうのは責任放棄ではなく
責任が嫌になるほどあるんです
膨大な数の戒律とサンガ組織の規則がたくさんあります
覚えられないから私も結構間違えますよ
ありすぎちゃって で 食を食べることも修行です
それは在家の 例えば これ例えばの話
出家っていうのは食と言葉を使うんだけど
午前中なら3回食べてもいいんです
あの  1食にするんですね
で  1食食べるくらい 出家したら食事することも修行になるんです
迷惑でしょ みんなもう仕事をして
気分気持ちよく気分爽快になるためにご飯を食べているのに
出家にはそれも修行の一つで
なぜならば あの食べるご飯は在家の布施なんです
だから汚れた心で あ これって美味しいね
あ これすごい豪華な食べ物ですねとかね
あ 出家してよかった 毎日結構ごちそうを食えるんだとかね
お釈迦様ははっきりあんたは直行地獄にしますよ
すごい厳しく言うんです
だから特別専門用語がありますよ
だからお坊さんの皿に入るご飯は借り食いなんです
いわゆる返さなくちゃあかんです
借りているんです それから汚染食という単語もあります
要するにお坊さんがだらしない
自分の修行も放棄して責任放棄で
楽に贅沢に食べて 贅沢なお寺で住んでいる状態だったら汚染食なんです
この場合は食べるものが汚染している
だから汚染されたものを食べたら毒でしょ
だから出家したら気楽に一つご飯食べることすらできなくなるんです
そこの中に修行があるんです
だから我々は長い習慣だからね
よく冗談言ったり いろんなことを人を馬鹿にしたりしながら食べますけど
これはお布施であってということは決して忘れることはないんです
いくら美味しそうに見えるものがあっても
食いまくるんじゃないのだと知っているんです
時々お布施する人の顔を見て
なんかかわいそうで これを受けなかったら
この人はなんか気持ち悪くなるかもしれませんと
慈しみではいどうぞどうぞと
だからそういうところで食べたくないものも食べたりするんです
こんなのは私の体に悪いんだけど
食べて でも相手がすごい真剣にね
自分の不幸をなんとか苦毒を背負ってなんとかしたいという気持ちで来たら
はい わかります はい どうぞどうぞと言って食べるんですよ
だからそんな楽ちんな生き方じゃないんです
でも表面的にそう見えるんです
それがもう我々のポイントなんです
すごく明るくニコニコと笑っているんです
裏は見せません 舞台と同じです
舞台の裏と俳優さんたちのあの厳しい徹夜してやる訓練は見せないんです
ちゃんと正しく ウォーキング
いろんな歩き方で歩いて
美しく歌って芸をして出ていくんです
それだけ見ていいねと羨ましがってもね
裏は違うんですよ 映画の場合でもね
世界的に人気ある女優さん
俳優さんとかね 裏はそうじゃないんでしょうね
あの 1 秒 2 秒で演じなくちゃあかんです
見事に はい と 出家重役を施す在家仏教徒の指導者
アドバイザー 先輩としての義務もあります
修行する義務の上で仏教徒がいるんだからね
在家の だから両方いないと仏教成り立ちませんだから
その人々のアドバイザーになって
指導者になって 何か落ち込んだら
それは何とかしてあげたり
それもやらなくちゃいけないんです
清らかな出家生活をする義務
心を清らかにする義務 2つです
悟らなくたっても 毎日清らかな心でいるように頑張らなくちゃいけない
それから完全心 煩悩を落とす修行もしなくちゃいけないという 2つはメイン義務になっています
はい ブッダの教えを学んで理解することも必要です
能力があれば他人に教えること
仏教を伝道することなどの義務もあります
夜逃げじゃないんです
だから我々にはボスがいないんですよ
出家には ローマ教会 教皇みたいなポープみたいなボスがいないんです
お坊さんたちの先輩後輩いるんだけど
みんなサンガ同じ平等です
なのに仏教は 2500年以上も守ったんです
だから一人一人責任持っているんです
私も仏教を伝道しなくちゃいけないんです
次の世代を作らなくちゃいけないんだと
それはできなくなるとすごく嫌な気持ちになるんです
ですから 我々は弟子を作る場合は
若い子供たち 大体取るんですよ
でも 子供たちは親から離れたからといって
子供たちは親と一緒にいるよりもすごく充実感があって
ものすごく元気で頑張るんです
だから 親の愛情よりも慈しみを我々はあげるんです
あげて育てるんです だからみんな子供は勉強を嫌がっているとかね
登校を拒否しているとかね
我々出家している子供たちにそういう問題は一切ないんです
ないんです みんな勝手に元気で頑張るんです
だからどうですかね 我々の子育ての方法は
私ね もう二十歳になりかかっている若者がいるんだけど
私もびっくりするほど
ものの見事に勉強はいつでも第一で合格しているんです
誰も褒めてあげる人はいないんです
だから そんなすごい責任がある世界なんです
一人の比丘にすべての義務を完全に果たすことは現実的に不可能です
だから出家したら 私はすべての責任を果たしてやると
これはできないんです
だから 自分の能力に合わせて自分にできることをするんです
解脱を目指すことは第一にして
義務責任の優先順位を設定して出家は修行します
これ 在家世界にそれはないでしょう
優先順位とか我々にあるんです
優先順位で一番下のものは
時々やる時間なくなっちゃってサボってしまったことはあります
優先順位があるんです
経典では誰にでも出家を求めるように求めたように読めますが
裏があります 何か経典を読んでいるとお釈迦様
私は出家したいと言ったら
お釈迦様はい どうぞ 終わり
なんだ 簡単簡単単純じゃないと思いますね
裏があるんです 社会状況はどうであっても
要するに社会の奴隷であっても
不可触民族であっても
お釈迦様のところに出家したいと思ったら
お釈迦様はいいよ 終わり
お釈迦様は儀式やりませんだからね
いいですよ 頑張りなさい
その一言葉で出家なんです
皆に解脱に達する能力があったんです
だから経典に出てくる出家はみんな悟ったんです
そう それで我々のサンガにお釈迦様が責任を委託したところで
我々は人を選択するんです
だってわからんだからね
はい それであの出家は自由はてな
サンバドガラアワスアブーカースバッチャーというブッダの言葉があるんですね
俗世間は煩わしい 出家は空のように開放的だと
出家の自由を謳っているプレイス
結構あるんです 特にスッタニパータなんかでも結構あるんですね
でもちょっと何でも裏があるんだからしょうがないんですよ
で 在家には煩悩があるので
責任果たすことさえも束縛なんです
苦しいんです 私たちは子供を育てるような感じで
自分の子供でもないのに
あんな気楽で遊びながらできませんよ
束縛になるんです 責任を果たすっても
悩み苦しみは消えないんですよ
在家の場合は 心に煩悩が消えたら
心が大空のように自由になるんです
だから出家して心の煩悩が消えたら
すべて責任がなくなっているんです
心は大空のようになるんです
それを謳っているんです
凡夫は出家したところで解脱を目指して修行に励むための条件が揃っているので
相対的に自由を感じるんです
だから誰かさんがね お釈迦様の親戚の王子たちも出家したら
まだ悟ってないんだけど
あー好き 自由だ 楽しいんだ
楽しいんだと言うんです
それでみんななんだ この人は変やと
もしかすると減税したくなっているんじゃないと言ったら
この人言うんですね 在家時だとか
いつでもガードの人々が周りにいたんだと
寝る時でも誰かが部屋の外で待っているんだと
警備してた そこで公園に遊びに行ったっても
自分が誰かに殺されるかないかと不安でしょうがなかったんだと
今私は一人でいるんだよと
あの怯えが一切ないんだと
だから公園で自由に歩けるんだよと
だからまだ悟ってないんです
だから修行できる環境が出来上がっちゃうんだから
それも出家する人は自由として感じるんですね
しかし 束縛にならないが出家組織は俗世間よりも責任義務が多い社会です
束縛はないんです はい
そこで結論のところに行きます
自利利他の合体 あの いろいろ皆様寄せられた質問にも
その中に答えがあると思います
出家は自分の解脱のみを目指す自利行ではありません
すごい勘違いしているんです
大乗仏教みたいに大丈夫かいいんです
どうせ脱線しちゃったんだから
道からね 自利を置いて他のために苦労する迷惑なお世話人でもないんです
観音さんみたいにいないんだからいいんだけど
観音さんの物語では 観音様がすべての生命を救いたいんですね
本人がいいんです 俺はみんな解脱に達するまで悟りに達しませんと
迷惑ですよ 自から悪をなくすこと
他人にも努めること 自から煩悩を断つこと
他人にも努めることが出家修行です
え？進めること だから自利利他と区別できないんです
だから自分には他人に
例えば煩悩がよくない
やっぱり煩悩を控えめにしましょうとかね
最低殺生ぐらいやめなくちゃという気持ちにさせることをできないならば
私の修行に問題があるんです
ですから 私は一度たりとも酒飲むなよと言ってないでしょ
この私の長い人生の中で
日本でもう年取ってあって
今そろそろ死ぬでしょ？でも相当いるでしょ
酒飲まない人々は テーラワーダ仏教の仲間になってから
その秘密は何ですかね
いちいちガチャガチャあれやるなかれ
これやるなかれ 言ってないんです
それが修行の結果なんです
いつでもやるかやらないか
あなた自由だよ 私は内容だけ説明してあげますよと
といったスタンスで説明してるでしょう
だからこれはもうそれで自分も修行しているという証拠になっているし
相手もそれで正しい道を歩んでいるんです
それで修行が成り立っているんです
己の解脱だけを目指すことこと
自我の壁は破れませんよ
だからみんな悪口を言うんですね
だからこのメールでやった質問の中でも
何か一言悪口あってね
まあ自分だけのことを考えるでしょうね
しかっていうのははっきり言ってなかったんだけどね
これはもう脱線している方々の考えなんです
軌道から飛んじゃったんです
だからどこへ行くかわからないんです
そこで誰かさんが俺が必ず悟ってやる
みんなと喋ることもやめると言って
わがまま自分だけに解脱してみんなに見せてやろうではなくったら
絶対悟れないだけではなくて
サマーディこすら作れないんです
だって自我が強すぎなんです
だから正確に評価すると
サイケよりも以下なんです
こちらに来た方々もまあ少ないんだけど
私からはい 合格 解脱に達しました
合格しましたとハンコ押してもらいたくて
人々人は仏教そのものをやめて出て行ったんです
だから仏教徒じゃないんで
初めからもう私にハンコを押す権利がないんだから
人は自我 自我破ったら悟っているんです
だから卵の場合は 殻を破ることは卵の中にいるヒヨコの仕事です
誰がパパッと全部卵の殻を割っちゃうとみんな死ぬでしょうに
はい 解脱は出家だけの特権ではありません
ブッダが人類に語ったんです
在家も自分の生活環境の中で自利利他合体の生活するのです
出家だけではなく 在家も自利利他合体生き方しなくちゃいけないんです
で 経典引用するならばありますよ
まあ時間ないんだから
まあ引用します 最初にいきます
仏法は出家 なんで出家修行者の講義というはてな
だから経典読んでみたら
お釈迦様があの講義やってるんですね
比丘たちに だから在家の人々は我々には関係ないよ
これはと 在家に教えた話はありますかねとかね
はい 次 仏法の理解と適用の仕方
当然 出家に語った教えの教えは膨大です
当たり前でしょ 王様たち
農民 商人 一般家の一般在家に語られた教えもありますよ
あんまりこの残ってない場合もありますからね
だってワンパターンだからね
で まあそんなに珍しくもないしね
だからまあお釈迦様は毎日托鉢に行くんだからね
毎日在家の方々に説法しましたよ
在家の説法は 俗世間の問題
社会関係 悪の道から離れて善行為を善行為をなんか間違ってますね
善行為をする生き方などの内容ですね
そんなに難しい理論に入らないんです
家族のことやら まあそういう例えばね
奥さんにたまたまプレゼントあげなさいと
あの装飾品をあげなさいよとかね
そんな時の話 必ず褒めなさいよと
今まで男やってないでしょ？お釈迦様は一生っておっしゃってます
在家に いかなる場合でも
自分の奥さんをけなしてはならん
褒めるんです だから でもそんなのはまあまあ一家相でやるだけで
だーっとそればっかり書いてるわけじゃないんでしょ
仏教は正しく仕事をこなす方法だけ知って
仏教として十分ではないんでしょ
奥さんの機嫌取る方法だけ学んだら十分だと思う
奥さんたちは料理の仕方
旦那の管理だけお寺に来て学んで
それで十分 惨めでしょうね
真理を知るべきですよ
在家も 生きるとは何と知るべきなんです
一旦 俗世間のあの煩わしい生き方からちょっと休む
休憩取って ちょっと仏教のことを学ばなくてはいかんですね
ですから 在家も仏法をできるだけたくさん学ぶんです
自分が生きる社会環境に合わせて修行するんです
だから ミャンマー人の在家と日本人の在家に環境違うんだからね
それに合わせて修行の仕方も変わります
こちらで宿泊瞑想会やる場合は
どこかの安いホテルでも我々借りたりするでしょ
ミャンマー人は来てないんです
それだけ こちらは在家が来て泊まって宿泊して瞑想できるお寺がありません
だから この自分が生きている環境に合わせて修行すればいいでしょうに
在家の悟り 出家の悟りという分類はありません
悟りは悟りです それで出家にも説法する能力がある
在家いますよ 今もいますよ
在家ですけど 結構立派に説法するんです
お坊さんたちも若い人々はじっと聞いて学ぶんです
だから全然問題ないんです
自己観察気づきの実践は出家
在家同じです 修行は同じです
経典を学ぶ時 出家はどのように実践するのか
在家はどのように実践するのかと自己判断できるように語られていることわかります
もう一度読んでみてください
日本語訳でもいいんです
なんてなく読む人にとってはこの経典
私が実践するならばどうすればいいかと
ちゃんと案があるんです
盲信する宗教ではないので
自分自身の理解能力を駆使して仏教を学ぶんです
解脱に達する道を不放逸という一単語に集約しています
出家も在家も不放逸で全て仏道です
はい それで終わりとは思います
時間も飛びで飛んでしまいましたけどね
本当に長い時間ありがとうございます
で では終了しますかね
はい 回向 はい 終了しましょうか
はい それでは皆様 聞いている方々もね
回向の文章を唱えてください
あらゆる生命に憐れみを持って真理を説かれた本師釈迦牟尼仏陀の聖なる教えに従い
我々がここまで積んだすべての功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって 生きとし生けるもののすべてが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱を得られますように
サードゥ サードゥ サードゥ
サッビーとイヴァージャントーサッバローゴ виナサトーマーテーバワットアンテラーヨ
スキーディーガーユコーバババーティサッバマンガランラッカヌサッバデヴァターサッバブッダヌーバヴェーナサッバダンマーヌーバヴェーナサッバサンガーヌーバヴ
ェーナサダースッティバワントゥテーアーユラーローゲサンパッティサッバサンパッティメーウェチャアトーニンバーナサンパッティイミナーテシャミンジョトゥ
はい ありがとうございます
カンティーパラマンタポーティティンカーニッバーナンパラマンワダンティーブッダ